Speaker 1: All right, we have two more of
these, quite frankly, very sad stories about
COVID deaths, even though these are what some
people call just this in some way, I still find
these very sad. Let's start with the first one
a dozen or more of you e-mailing me. This deputy
district attorney who opposed vaccine mandates
has died from COVID at 46 years old. Kelly Irby
was a Republican. She ran for California State
Assembly in 2020. She said there's nothing that
matters more than our freedoms right now at
a rally against vaccine mandates. Last month,
she is now dead. This was the Orange
County Deputy District Attorney, Kelly R&B.
California Republican activists opposed vaccine
mandates of all kinds. Her boss, District Attorney
Todd Spitzer, announced her death on Facebook.
Quote The Orange County District Attorney's
Office is utterly heartbroken by the sudden and
unexpected passing of Deputy District Attorney
Kelly earned B. Kelly was an incredibly vibrant,
passionate attorney who cared deeply about the
work that we do as prosecutors and deeply about
the community we all fight so hard to protect.
Ben Chapman, chair of the
Greater Costa Mesa Republicans,
praised R&B as an inspiration and confirmed
she died from COVID complications.
My heart is broken and I'm in tears, wrote Ben.
I lost a dear friend to COVID complications.
R&B ran an unsuccessful campaign for
California State Assembly in 2020.
In December, she spoke against vaccine mandates
at a rally organized by the right wing student
group Turning Post USA. Now, I actually don't know
if that's an error, and they meant Turning Point
USA. I was not able to find that definitively, but
in any case, she, in speaking against all vaccine
mandates, said there's nothing that matters
more than our freedoms right now, 46 years old.
And she has died of COVID and it is just
another one of these reminders that listen, I'm
with you, I'm with you. And the science in saying
this disproportionately is hitting older people.
This disproportionately is hitting unhealthy
people. Obesity is a big risk factor,
number of other things. But when you've got a
bell curve distribution, or even in this case,
what may be a perito distribution skewed towards
the older and the the people with comorbidities?
When you have a planet of nearly eight
billion people, you're going to get
random younger, in some cases, perfectly healthy
people that are going to die. And if it were me,
I don't want to take that chance. Might my dad the
other day sent me a great analogy to winter tires,
which is, you know, sometimes all season
tires are perfectly fine, even in winter.
Sometimes you can go an entire winter and it
doesn't even snow in the northeast or places
where it snows. Sometimes it can snow and
you've got the all season tires and you slip,
but you don't crash. But wouldn't you rather
still have the winter tires because there might
be a situation where they really do protect you
and prevent you from getting into an accident?
That's really the perspective on the vaccination
stuff. So 46 year old R&B has died of COVID,
and we have another one of these stories
that in some sense, is even more bizarre.